nous sommes en présence de Jean-Claude
nimbaud un des plus fidèles et éminents
serviteurs du zouk qui sera en concert
le 10 février prochain dans la grande
salle de l'Atrium de force de France
Jean-Paul Nemours dans ce sera le
premier le tout premier concert solo
après plus de 50 ans de carrière
première question évidemment pourquoi
avoir attendu aussi longtemps
Jean-Claude il y a plusieurs raisons à
ça
avec Kassav pendant 40 ans on n'a pas
été tourné donc je n'ai jamais eu le
temps de me poser pour faire mon propre
concert c'était beaucoup plus facile
pour des personnes comme Jean-Philippe
ou Jocelyne qui reviennent au pays entre
deux tournées mais moi j'habite Paris
c'est compliqué voilà ça c'est la
première raison la deuxième c'est que je
suis quelqu'un de perfectionniste
Emmanuel Césaire qui me tente depuis des
années de venir faire un concert je lui
ai toujours dit que je ferai le concert
en temps et en heure faut pas aller plus
vite que la musique et la troisième
raison c'est que étant perfectionniste
il fallait que je trouve le bon
équilibre entre déjà les tous les titres
que j'ai composé à l'intérieur du groupe
Kassav mais à l'extérieur aussi pour
d'autres et trouver la bonne alchimie et
aussi trouver les bons invités parce que
moi j'ai toujours pensé que le jour où
je ferai un concert il fallait que je
mélange les
générations il a fallu que je fasse un
choix dans mes titres ça m'a pris un
certain temps il a fallu que je
choisisse une direction avec mon chef
d'orchestre qui est Didier davides une
direction parce que je ne voulais pas
faire un copier-coller des titres les
prendre tels qui sont dans les originaux
et puis les rejouer donc on a choisi
volontairement d'avoir une direction un
peu rock pour ce premier concert et et
ça demande du travail
[Musique]
la sortie avec ce qui sortit dans ma
tête à ce moment-là et puis voilà on
aurait également avec qui tu as
travaillé oui mais manucides
avec Peter Gabriel lors de la tournée
habiter au Gabriel c'est cela et ainsi
que Billy qui était dans cette tournée
là puisqu'il a remplacé Manu 4G pendant
3-4 mois oui et puis une fois
au sein du groupe Kassav il y a eu
encore d'autres rencontres d'autres
belles rencontres d'autres belles
expériences je pense à Edith Lefel dans
cette anniversaire de la mort récemment
je pense à la qui sera à l'affiche avec
toi le 10 on va en reparler Peter
Gabriel on la cité est-ce que parmi
toutes ces contributions il y en a une
qui t'a particulièrement marqué
Dieu Gabriel parce que c'est d'abord
parce que je suis parti un an et demi
avec lui mon anglais était
tourné mondiale on a vraiment fait
pratiquement toute la planète
et à l'époque mon anglais n'était pas il
a fallu que je m'adapte très vite parce
qu'il y avait 80 personnes sur la
tournée et j'étais le seul francophone
avec Manu Katché donc il a fallu que je
m'adapte la langue très vite
voilà il a fallu que je m'adapte très
vite à
l'ambiance parce que les anglais sont
ils ne fonctionnent pas comme nous mais
ça a eu l'avantage de me donner un côté
de ma carrière on va dire
que j'avais déjà mais qui s'est accentué
avec le en étant de
en contact de Peter Gabriel c'est la
rigueur anglaise et ça je pense que ça
rejaillit un petit peu sur Kassav' parce
que comme je suis quelqu'un de Rigaud
j'ai encore plus vu le côté
à quel point la rigueur peut amener à
des choses encore plus merveilleuses et
plus grandes quand on quand on s'y tient
donc c'est ça toujours été mon objectif
et mon rôle dans le groupe que ça va
après donc les Anglais m'ont donné ça et
je suis ravi de cette expérience de d'un
an et demi à travers le monde et puis
après il y a qu'à ça évidemment le Graal
qu'à savent c'est c'est 40 ans de ta vie
d'artiste avec le groupe et plus de 50
ans de carrière donc
des copains d'abord une seconde famille
au fond je crois que je crois que tu as
eu l'occasion de le dire en interview
qu'est-ce qui reste de cette épopée en
toute sincérité que la boucle est
bouclée tient je crois que c'est une
formule que tu as envoyé récemment
tout dépend de point de vue on se place
quand on dit la boucle bouclée puisque
le groupe
existe encore
mais en tout cas on a donné pendant 40
ans de notre vie puisqu'on a pas trop eu
le temps d'avoir une vie de famille on
l'a eu entre nous cette vie de famille
je n'ai pas vu ma fille naître je ne
l'ai pas vu grandir
et la fille qui est tombée
oui un peu mon manager
mon bras droit mais ma conscience ma
mémoire
et tout cela s'est fait sans qu'on ait
eu le temps de
voir ce qui se passait parce que le
groupe au départ
moi-même j'y suis rentré il était déjà
là depuis deux ans le groupe il existait
depuis deux ans mais
je ne comptais pas comme j'ai dit à
Jacob au départ rester dans le groupe je
suis quelqu'un de sauvage de très
individuel
d'individualiste sauvage exagérons oui
non je le me déplaît pas je suis je suis
voilà je suis Lyon donc voilà et je suis
dans la poésie chinoise je suis chat il
y a rien de plus individualiste qu'un
chat donc je revendique ça je j'ai
mauvais caractère donc je ne suis pas
quelqu'un qui
de facilement je n'adapte pas facilement
à l'idée d'un groupe d'ailleurs quand
j'étais plus jeune j'ai toujours refusé
comme mes parents m'envoient dans les
colonies de vacances et les choses comme
ça donc ce qui explique mon côté un peu
[Musique]
que les gens trouvent que je suis un peu
lunatique un peu arrogant un peu voilà
mais ça ne me dérange nullement il se
trompe surtout je ne sais pas des fois
peut-être que je peux être arrogant des
fois parce que ça dépend tous les points
de comment on me on m'aborde
autant je peux être généreux gentil avec
des gens mais je déteste la trop grande
familiarité donc voilà je suis comme ça
je suis comme ça je vais pas me changer
mais ceci dit
ça des côtés un peu quand tu es artiste
ça des côtés qui peuvent être perçus
comme négatif pour le public alors j'ai
essayé de
d'arrondir un peu ces angles là au long
des tout au long de ma carrière sans
trop y arriver mais bon ça a des bons et
des mauvais côtés je pense que quand tu
te disperses un peu trop quand tu es
trop dans le panier problème machin bon
ça ne t'amène pas grand chose c'est pas
très professionnel tout à fait au début
on se rappelle au début de Kass avec
l'âge et des productions la belle de
Georges DEPS regretté Georges depse qui
était le premier producteur de la du
groupe
il y avait une on s'en souvient une
sorte de stratégie qui avait été initié
c'est-à-dire entre deux albums de
Kassav' il y avait un ou deux disques
solo c'était plutôt bien vu est-ce que
c'est un remake de cette formule qui se
dessine aujourd'hui en 2023 pour
garantir la continuité de la formation
mise en mode Scénic cette fois avec ton
digital taux puisque avant il y a eu le
chaouatou de Jocelyne béouard et donc
qu'est-ce que c'est un petit peu vers
cette formule là que vous êtes en train
de vous orienter je crois que dans ce
groupe là on sait jamais trop posé de
questions quand on fait quelque chose on
le fait parce qu'on le sent
il s'est trouvé que Jocelyne depuis au
moins 10 ans parlait
d'un livre qu'elle voulait sortir c'est
fait le covid a les choses puisque en
fait on s'est arrêté de tourner moi de
mon côté le covid m'a permis de
m'arrêter aussi pour penser à ma
carrière solo enfin carrière solo à mon
à ce que j'ai envie de faire tout seul
maintenant
comme je te le disais tout à l'heure on
n'a pas trop de réflexion
à longue échelle à longue échéance on se
dit pourquoi pas faire ça ça c'est
possible c'est possible c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible on renvoie
demain là par exemple
j'ai commencé digital taux avec deux
concerts ici au Trianon à Paris mais
rien ne dit que ça va ça va perdurer
peut-être que ça va ça va s'arrêter à
deux concerts pourquoi parce que on n'a
pas perdu l'idée que en 2023 on va faire
un hommage Jacob et d'une tournée et une
tournée qui m'amènera le manager
François Pinard est un travail dessus
qui ma mémoire qui nous amènera
peut-être
à travers le monde pendant un an ou deux
gens je ne sais rien si tu veux les
choses on est obligé de de faire les
choses par rapport à aux événements qui
arrivent mais la réflexion est en cause
la formation absolument maintenant quant
à la relève quant à la suite a donné la
suite oui la suite c'est par rapport
comme je te dis aux événements qui vont
se passer par rapport à Kassav
maintenant la relève quand on parle le
relève j'avoue que je ne sais pas trop
ce que ça veut dire pourquoi
je me sens un peu nous nous sentons un
peu harcelés depuis des années je vois
si vous les réseaux les gens nous dire
ah oui mais jamais rien fait pour les
jeunes je profite de l'occasion pour
dire que Jacob des vario paix à son âme
a fait quand même le grand méchant zouk
pour mettre en lumière les générations
d'après nous
on a fait le concours du rêve antillais
où sont sortis des gens comme Pascal
Valo le premier absolument ou
rotin oui Jean-Michel donc à ceux qui
disent qu'on n'a jamais fait pour les
jeunes qu'ils auront qu'ils se
renseignent mais au-delà de ça j'ai
envie de leur répondre autre chose si
vous prenez toutes les stars mondiales
Nick Jagger Bob Marley Michael Jackson
ou bien d'autres ils ont fait quoi pour
les jeunes générations rien du tout 0
pourquoi parce qu'il y a deux choix dans
la vie soit tu mènes ta carrière tu
l'amènes jusqu'au bout soit tu dis
j'arrête et je fais une école mais tu ne
peux pas faire les deux tu veux pas dire
je suis en tournée mais je vais faire
pour les jeunes c'est ça n'existe nulle
part ailleurs au monde alors quand les
gens nous disent qu'on ne fait rien pour
les jeunes j'ai envie de leur dire
regardez qu'est-ce que Marley que tout
le monde adore qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
pour les jeunes je ne sais pas mais j'ai
pas entendu dire qu'il a fait quoi que
ce soit bref
une troisième chose
quand vous êtes au plein milieu de votre
carrière
tu es obligé de penser toujours à demain
demain qu'est-ce que tu fais demain
c'est pas comme si tu es arrivé à un
stade où tu t'assies sur le fauteuil
comme pour d'autres métiers et puis tu
peux vous regarder autour de toi tu es
bien obligé de continuer jusqu'à la fin
de ta vie à créer tu ne peux pas en même
temps avoir une vie de créateur et puis
une vie de professeur ces deux métiers
qui n'ont rien à voir absolument rien à
voir soit tu es professionnel de musique
soit tu es un chanteur compositeur ou je
ne sais quoi je peux pas me réveiller le
matin et puis me dire je vais composer
parce que composer c'est pas comme dit
mon père et l'expression rédis chaise
motable ça soit là et puis dit tu as
fait un morceau en 5 minutes voilà le
morceau alors précisément si on jette un
oeil sur demain tu as 71 ans aujourd'hui
et plus de 50 ans de carrière je l'ai
rappelé au compteur qu'est-ce qu'on a
envie d'écrire avec une telle carrière
derrière soi envie de chanter envie de
dire sur scène en interview comme nous
le faisons en ce moment ou dans un
bouquin peut-être possible exemple non
je bouquet ça m'a jamais intéressé si
d'autres ont envie d'écrire un livre sur
moi ça c'est ça c'est le moment ça
m'intéresse pas moi ce qui comme je
disais à mon ami Jean-Paul Joanel tout à
l'heure il y a pas plus tard d'une
demi-heure je ne regarde jamais dans le
rétroviseur je ce qui m'intéresse c'est
ce que je vais faire demain quand les
gens me parlent tu as fait si tu as fait
ça oui ok mais moi
[Musique]
que j'ai fait hier avant hier ça ne
m'intéresse pas on va terminer en jetant
un œil sur la fiche mais auparavant j'ai
tout de même une question à te poser sur
le zouk la le futur du zouk sa
consolidation s'allonger vite et passe
d'après toi par quel prise de conscience
quelle stratégie et qu'elle
accompagnement c'est une question
c'est une question je le reconnais
difficile parce que
les jeunes et je peux le comprendre
n'écoute pas les générations d'avance ça
ne les intéresse pas ils font leur truc
et je le comprends personne n'est venu
nous dire au début il faut faire comme
si il faut faire comme ça il y avait
avant une musique nous on a créé la
nôtre et les jeunes générations qui
arrivent à eux de créer la leur
maintenant s'ils veulent avoir des
conseils on est là pour leur donner des
conseils mais est-ce que finalement nos
conseils serviront aux jeunes dans la
mesure où chaque génération à ses codes
complètement différent nous on avait on
est arrivé avec
le début des ordinateurs le début des
synthés maintenant on est passé à autre
chose on est passé à une génération où
l'image est plus importante que la
musique il y a eu les home studios et
puis aujourd'hui on tourne un clip avec
avec un portable mais au-delà de ça
c'est pas important de savoir si on le
trouve avec un portable c'est de savoir
à quel niveau tu mets la musique par
rapport à l'image nous l'image servait
de support à la musique maintenant la
musique sert de support à l'image ça
veut dire quand tu dis la musique c'est
les textes la profondeur non la musique
quand tu as écouté
pour te donner un exemple bien simple
j'ai écouté une interview d'une petite
jeune dernièrement pas forcément
antillaise mais à Paris qui disait on
lui posait la question sur son dernier
album et toutes ces réponses étaient
branchées
sur où elle va tourner son clip dans le
désert de Tunisie ou le c'est-à-dire que
les jeunes maintenant la musique
représente 20%
et l'image représente 80% quel vêtement
va avoir quel maquillage il va avoir
mais la musique est un support alors que
nous à notre époque c'était 80% de
musique et 20% du clip c'est pour ça que
je te dis je peux pas donner un conseil
quel qu'il soit un jeune puisque les
codes ne sont plus les mêmes l'avenir
sera encore pire à mon avis et si la
musique ne représente que 1% d'ailleurs
je serai peut-être plus de ce monde mais
elle va de plus en plus être robotisée
la musique donc on arrivera dans un
monde où la musique
prendra de moins en moins d'importance
sauf si les choses changent je ne sais
pas par commentaire et que mais
l'histoire de Quincy Jones les beaux
arrangements les soucis c'est bien loin
de nous maintenant
parce que j'ai perdu aussi de cette
habitude cette mauvaise habitude de dire
c'était mieux avant je ne veux plus
entendre parler de je ne veux plus dire
je le disais et je me suis rendu compte
que je suis dans le faux c'était pas
mieux avant ni après c'est notre nous on
était comme ça on avait James Brown on
avait Otis Redding on avait on trouvait
ça merveilleux avec la chose
c'est comme ça les jeunes tu leur posera
la question qu'est-ce qui préfèrent
James Brown ou Beyoncé ils vont te dire
donc tu pourras leur dire jusqu'à demain
ouais mais dans Beyoncé il y a pas
tellement de musique dans genevois il y
avait de la musique s'Il veut Il y avait
oui mais une fois que tu auras dit ça tu
auras fait quoi tous les jours tu les
auras pas perçu à des qu'il faut écouter
la musique depuis des années 80 donc
chacun vit en son temps et moi je refuse
d'avoir des conflits de génération
chacun vit dans son temps alors la fiche
de 10 février belle affiche avec des
invités ça sera on le rappelle à
tropicatrium mais une petite salle on
entend déjà que le public dit en mais
oui mais c'est quand même les mots
pourquoi la trium et une soldate les
mêmes qui te disent ça c'est les mêmes
qui ne vont pas remplir le stade de
Dylan si j'y suis
donc là aussi c'est un choix réfléchi
réfléchis réfléchi je fais avec les
moyens
je design il y a pas de si longtemps que
ça qui me prétendait que j'étais aussi
star que je suis par exemple j'ai dit
non je vais te dire pourquoi et ne
comprenait pas pourquoi je dis écoute
dans le groupe Casa pendant 40 ans
jocelyne et Jacob ont été choisis pour
s'occuper des médias donc tu passes 40
ans tu vois jocelyne et Jacob à la télé
tous les jours que Dieu fait tu ne peux
pas au bout de 40 ans comparer cette
image de quelqu'un que tu vois tous les
jours à l'image de Nemo que tu ne vois
jamais
dans la tête des gens je ne suis je suis
bon il y a des gens qui connaissent bien
qu'à ça qui l'ont dit voilà le pianiste
mais
tout se construit dans la vie moi j'ai
construit une image de quelqu'un dans
l'ombre qui fait le travail de le faire
oui dans en tout cas qui fait un travail
d'ombre dans le groupe parce que j'ai
choisi ça et parce que on a décidé ça
donc pas plus tard qu'hier j'étais au
studio DJ Jackson il y a des petits
jeunes qui autre
et Jackson dit ou pas qu'on admission
oui tu vois tu comprends donc je ne peux
pas provenir à ta question initiale dit
je vais faire dit long de mai parce que
si je fais du long de mai je me plante
en pensant que comme je sors le Kassav
je vais faire 10000 personnes à 10 long
faux donc prudence toujours je préfère
faire une scène latrium où je un jour ou
la salle je l'espère sera pleine
plutôt que d'aller penser que je vais
remplir ceci cela et puis que je me
plante voilà c'est aussi simple que ça
voilà maintenant
les gens sont contents du conseiller et
me redemande de revenir en Martinique et
bien on verra si on fait plus grand si
voilà
une capacité d'environ 1000 spectateurs
donc ça te va ça me va très bien oui
les gens qui pour qui j'ai composé
pendant ces 40 ans
Jocelyne d'abord la première Encasa
marbre qui j'ai composé pas mal de
morceaux
et puis j'ai voulu comme je disais avoir
dans mon dans mon dans mes invités des
gens de génération complètement
différente Tony c'est une génération
intermédiaire c'est quelqu'un que
j'apprécie énormément et qui en même
temps mon directeur artistique pour le
spectacle donc j'ai trouvé qui faisait
partie intégrante du show et puis un
petit jeune qui s'appelle Gregs qui est
dans le groupe gicom c'est la jeune
génération donc je trouve que réunis
tous ces gens là
vont normalement m'aider à produire en
bons spectacle et puis il y aura des
surprises une grosse surprise une visite
inattendue au restaurant il y aura des
petites des petits moments de
des respirations j'appelle ça comme ça
parce que la musique est faite aussi le
silence et d'émotion et d'émotion merci
Jean-Claude démo pour cet entretien
merci d'avoir échangé avec nous d'être
revenu un peu sur ta carrière je le
rappelle plus de 50 ans au service de la
musique antillaise du zouk en
particulier merci encore je t'en prie
c'est moi
[Musique]